is different from what theresa may and
david cameron
did before in that it is a break if you
like from the rules-based
international world order there is he
thinks
an emerging new world order in which
there's the rise of china
the rise of a more authoritarian
government and what does that mean
for the rules that have governed the
international order and western
democracies
for decades well it means he thinks
change and the prime minister will set
that all out in the commons
if we drill down into what the main
points the main ambition the vision
of the document is there is hope
if you like that democracies can
thrive and prosper and international
cooperation can
continue and with that in mind the main
ambition the prime minister will say for
the uk
is that climate change and protecting
biodiversity
will be as a country our number one
international
priority he will also recommit to
spending 0.7
of gross national income on overseas
development age you remember this was
very
contentious when the government decided
to temporarily cut
aid they said it was because of
coronavirus the crisis
so they'll recommit to that when the
fiscal situation
allows and then another aim is to secure
the uk
uk status as a science and tech
superpower by 2030 but
the risks as i was pointing to and the
recognition of growing
risks and instability is there too so
the prime minister in a big
reversal or changing policy if you like
will
increase the cap on nuclear warheads by
more than 40
to 240 there had been a cap of 180
warheads that ends the gradual decline
of nuclear weapons since the end
of the cold war a real nod there if you
like to not soft power
but hard power and i think he's in so
let's listen to him
on the government's integrated review of
security defense development and foreign
policy which we are publishing today
the overriding purpose of this review
the most comprehensive since the cold
war
is to make the united kingdom stronger
safer
and more prosperous while standing up
for our values
our international policy is a vital
instrument
for fulfilling this government's vision
of uniting and leveling up
across our country reinforcing the union
and securing britain's place as a
science superpower and a hub
of innovation and research the review
describes how we will bolster
our alliances strengthen our
capabilities
find new ways of reaching solutions and
re-learn the art of competing against
states
with opposing values we will be more
dynamic abroad and more focused on
delivering for our citizens at home
i begin with the essential fact that the
fortunes of the british people
are almost uniquely interlinked with
events
on the far side of the world with
limited natural resources we have always
earned our living as a maritime trading
nation
in 2019 the uk sold goods and services
overseas
worth 690 billion pounds fully a third
of our gdp sustaining millions of jobs
and livelihoods everywhere
from strand rare to some dives and
making our country the fifth biggest
exporter
in the world between five and six
million britons nearly one in ten of us
live permanently overseas including 175
000 in the gulf and nearly 2 million in
asia
and australasia so a crisis
in any of those regions or in the trade
routes connecting them
would be a crisis for us from the very
beginning the truth is that even if we
wished it
and of course we don't the uk could
never turn inwards or be content
with the cramped horizons of a regional
foreign policy
for us there are no far-away countries
of which
we know little global britain is not a
reflection
of old obligations still less of
vainglorious gesture but a necessity
for the safety and prosperity of the
british people in the decades
ahead and i'm determined that the uk
will join our friends
to ensure that free societies flourish
after the pandemic sharing the risks
and burdens of addressing the world's
toughest problems
the uk's presidency of the g7 has
already produced agreement to explore a
global treaty
on pandemic preparedness working through
the who
the world health organization to
enshrine the steps that countries will
need
to take to prevent another covid
we will host cop 26 in glasgow in
november
and rally as many nations as possible
behind the target of net zero
by 2050 leading by example
since the uk was the first major economy
to accept this obligation in law
britain will remain unswervingly
committed to nato
and preserving peace and security in
europe
and from this secure basis we will seek
out friends and partners
wherever they can be found building a
coalition for openness
and innovation and engaging more deeply
in the indo-pacific i have invited the
leaders of australia
south korea and india to attend the g7
summit in kabus bay
in june and i'm delighted to announce
that i will
visit india next month to strengthen our
friendship
with the world's biggest democracy
our approach will place diplomacy first
and the uk has applied to become a
dialogue partner of the association of
southeast
asian nations and we will seek
to join the trans-pacific free trade
agreement
but all our international goals rest
upon keeping our people safe at home
and deterring those who would do us harm
so we will create a counter-terrorism
operations center
bringing together our ability to thwart
the designs of terrorists
while also dealing with the actions of
hostile states
and it is almost exactly three years
since the
russian state used a chemical weapon in
salisbury
killing an innocent mother dawn sturgis
and bringing fear
to a tranquil city i can announce that
the national cyber force which conducts
offensive cyber operations against
terrorists hostile states
and criminal gangs will in future be
located in a cyber corridor
in the northwest of england
and we will also close mr speaker
and we will also establish a
cross-government situation center
in the cabinet office learning the
lessons of the pandemic
and improving our use of data to
anticipate
and respond to future crises
the first outcome of the integrated
review was the government's decision to
invest
an extra 24 billion pounds in defence
allowing the wholesale modernization of
our armed forces
and taking forward the renewal of our
nuclear
deterrent the new money will be focused
on mastering
the emerging technologies that are
transforming warfare
reflecting the premium placed on speed
and deployment
and technical skill and my right
honourable friend the defense secretary
will set out the details next week
later this year hms queen elizabeth will
embark on her maiden deployment
leading a carrier strike group on a 20
000 mile voyage
to the indo-pacific and back exercising
with britain's allies and partners along
the way
and demonstrating the importance we
attach to the freedom of the seas
by strengthening our armed forces we
will extend
british influence while simultaneously
creating jobs
across the united kingdom reinforcing
the union
and maximizing our advantage in science
and technology
this government will invest more in
research and development
than any of our predecessors because
innovation
is the key to our success at home
and abroad from speeding our economic
recovery to shaping emerging
technologies in accordance with freedom
and openness we will better protect
ourselves
against threats to our economic security
our newly independent trade policy will
be an instrument for ensuring that the
rules and standards
in future trade agreements reflect our
values
our newly independent sanctions policy
already allows
the uk to act swiftly and robustly
wherever necessary and we were the first
european country
to sanction the generals in myanmar
after the coup
last month in all our endeavors
the united states will be our greatest
ally
and a uniquely close partner in defence
intelligence
and security britain's commitment
to the security of our european home
will remain unconditional and immovable
incarnated by our leadership of nato's
deployment
in estonia we shall stand up for our
values
as well as for our interests and here i
commend the vigilance and dedication of
honourable members from all parties
because the uk with the wholehearted
support of
this whole house mr speaker has led the
international
community in expressing our deep concern
over china's mass detention of the
uyghur people
in xinjiang province and in giving
nearly three million
of hong kong's people a route to british
citizenship
there is no question that china will
pose a
great challenge for an open society such
as ours
but we will also work with china where
that is consistent
with our values and interests including
building a stronger and positive
economic relationship
and in addressing climate change
the greater our unity at home
the stronger our influence abroad
which will in turn open up new markets
and create jobs
in every corner of the uk not only
maximizing opportunities for the british
people
but also i hope inspiring a sense of
pride
that their country is willing to follow
in its finest
traditions and stand up for what is
right with the extra investment
and new capabilities of the integrated
review i believe
the united kingdom can thrive in an ever
more competitive world
and fulfill our historic mission
as a force for the good and i commend
this statement
to the house i know called the leader of
the opposition
kia stammer
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker we want this
integrated review to work
threats to our national security are
increasing they're becoming more complex
and less predictable
so the government has to get this right
but this review is built on foundations
that have been weakened
over the last decade the prime minister
has spoken of
an era of retreat he's right
in the last decade of conservative
government
defense spending and pay for the armed
forces
both fell in real terms our armed forces
numbers have been cut by 45 000
and there's still a black hole of 17
million in the defense
equipment plan so why we
whilst we do welcome the long overdue
increase in capital funding
we do welcome the creation of a
counterterrorism operations center
a new investment in cyber
the prime minister can't avoid the
question that everyone in our armed
forces and their families
will be asking today prime minister will
there be further cuts to the strength of
our army
and our armed forces the british army is
already six
thousand below the minimal level set out
in the last review
it's been cut every year for the last
decade
and it's being reported mr speaker that
the army
will see a further reduction of 10 000
alongside fewer tanks
fewer jets for the raf and fewer
frigates for the royal navy
prime minister if those reports are
untrue
can that be said today because mr
speaker successive conservative
prime ministers have cut the armed
forces
but at least they've had the courage to
come to this house and say so
this statement was silent on the issue
after everything the armed forces have
done for us the prime minister has a
duty
to be straight with them today
speaker turning to foreign policy
britain needs to be a moral force for
good
in the world once again leading the
fight against climate change
strengthening multinational alliances
including nato
championing human rights valuing
international development
and ensuring that trade deals protect
high standards
and public services but there's a huge
gap between that
and the government's actions the review
the review rightly concludes the review
rightly concludes
that russia remains the most acute
threat to our security
that's not new mr speaker 18 months ago
the russia review concluded
that the threat was urgent and immediate
so why have none of its recommendations
been implemented
the integrated review talks about the
importance of upholding international
law
i agree but from europe to the indian
ocean
this government now has a reputation for
breaking international law
not defending it we welcome the
deepening of engagement in the
indo-pacific region
but this comes on the back of an
inconsistent policy
towards china for a decade conservative
governments have spent ten years
turning a blind eye to human rights
abuses while inviting
china to help build our infrastructure
now that basic inconsistency
is catching up with them the review
also talks of conflict resolution
yet there's nothing about updating our
arms export regime
in particular suspending sales arms to
saudi arabia
the prime minister's statement mr
speaker didn't mention international
development once
and i wonder why because he's cutting
development spending for the first time
in decades
and denying this house a vote on it if
global britain is to mean anything it
cannot mean selling arms to saudi arabia
and cutting aid
to yemen mr speaker i voted for the
renewal of trident
and the labour party's support for
nuclear deterrence is
non-negotiable but this review
breaks the goal this review breaks the
goal of successive prime ministers
and cross-party efforts to reduce our
nuclear stockpile
it doesn't explain when why or for what
strategic purpose
so the prime minister needs to answer
that question today
on trade we recognize the need for new
and ambitious trade deals
there needs to be a major boost in uk
exports over the next decade
but that has to start with making a
success of the brexit deal
and that won't happen unless we remove
the new red tape
that's now holding british businesses
back
mr speaker britain should and could be a
moral force for good in the world
after a decade of neglect this review
was the chance to turn a corner
but there's now a very real risk that
our armed forces
will be stripped back even further and
that this review won't end the era of
retreat
in fact it'll extend it thank you mr
speaker
prime minister uh well mr speaker
first of all we have one of the toughest
arms uh export regimes in the world
under the consolidated guidance
uh anybody listening to uh him would uh
not realize mr speaker we're the second
biggest international donor
of aid in the in the g7 and i think it's
absolutely preposterous
uh to hear the the labor leader calling
for more
uh investment in our armed forces when
this is the biggest
investment in our armed forces since the
cold war and when it wasn't so long ago
our mr speaker 24 billion pounds once a
long ago he was campaigning
very hard very hard without dissent to
install a leader of the labour party as
prime minister who wanted to withdraw
from nato and disband
our armed forces and the right honorable
lady heckles me from the front bench mr
speaker but it's ridiculous
for him to talk about our nuclear
defenses mr speaker
when the reality is that labour is all
over the place
uh the shadow foreign secretary the last
time has
voted on our nuclear defenses protecting
our nuclear defensive speaker
the shadow foreign secretary voted
against it mr speaker and sure and so
did the current
labor deputy leader they want to talk
about standing up
for our armed forces mr speaker just in
the last year
the labour party has been given the
opportunity
to back our armed services our armed
forces
our troops our soldiers in the overseas
operations bill
they had the chance to stand up for
veterans they voted against it on a
three-line whip mr speaker those are the
instincts
of the labour party weak on supporting
our troops
weak on backing britain when it matters
and weak on defense
let's go to the father of the house sir
peter bottomley
mr speaker i think my random friend the
prime minister has pointed out
the present labour leadership is more on
the side of ernest bevin
who is against fascism and against
left-wing both at home and abroad i
think that's a sign of
some kind of unity the prime minister
didn't mention development much in his
statement and i'd ask whether he would
meet us
to have a discussion on it the question
of meeting the point seven percent
seventy pence every hundred pounds of
our income
has been agreed the government said it
will be maintained
it now says going to be a gap and it
will be restored
we want that gap to be evaporated
to go away not to happen the aid goes
down
with our income we should go up with our
income and we should meet the commitment
we've made
successive manifestos i'll leave it to
the prime minister
to say when it is that those who are
concerned for aid for yemen
and vso and others will actually get the
answer to whether they're going to be
cut
as well i want to stand beside the prime
minister as well as behind him
and we want to meet the commitment that
he wrote in our 2019 manifesto
proudly meeting that commitment yeah
mister
i'm grateful to my right honourable
friend and i think people listening to
this debate might uh not grasp because
actually this country is the biggest
european
donor uh to to yemen and given a billion
over the last uh six years 87 million
this year and i don't think they'd grasp
that actually we're giving
10 billion pounds in international aid
and i think we can be very proud
of what we're doing of course we will
return to the 0.7 target
when fiscal circumstances allow
right let us go to the leader of the smp
in blackford
in and thank you mr speaker let me thank
the prime minister for advance
copy of his statement and let me also
begin by thanking my snp colleagues led
by the
members for glasgow south in stirling
who compiled a very substantial and
constructive submission
on behalf of the snp during the reviews
consultation
mr speaker today's statement is one more
insight into just how hollow
the brand of global britain actually is
because the prime minister's rhetoric
always fails to come close to reality
today the prime minister preaches about
international obligation
but only yesterday our closest partners
in the eu are bringing his government to
court for breaking international law
the prime minister talks about
partnership with nations across the
world
in the very week that the most senior
figures in the us
including the speaker of congress warned
against the uk's increasingly
unilateralist approach the chasm between
the prime minister's rhetoric and the
reality of his government's actions
is deeply damaging just because he
wastes 2.6 million pounds
desperately trying to copy the white
house's press briefing room
doesn't hide the reality of the uk's
weakening
global influence so mr speaker
given our limited time let me ask a
number of
specific questions that we demand
answers to
on cuts to army personnel mr speaker we
were promised that twelve and a half
thousand personnel would be stationed
permanently in scotland the current
number remains well below
ten thousand and not only that it is
expected that cuts of ten thousand to
the army overall
will take place so what the prime
minister will be prepared to admit
that this is one more broken tory
promise to our armed forces and to the
people of scotland
and international aid cuts this review
fails to immediately reinstate our moral
obligation
and his party's manifesto commitment to
spend
0.7 percent on eden development under
this plan
countries devastated by war and famine
yemen
syria and south sudan will have their
humanitarian aid slashed
and only this morning it is emerging
that this uk government also plans
to cut its human rights support and
anti-corruption measures by a staggering
80 percent if the prime minister is
prepared to stand over these callous
cuts
is he also prepared to guarantee that he
will put a straight vote on this
in the house of commons and finally on
trident nuclear weapons
this review disgracefully endorses the
attainment
of 88 more of these weapons of mass
destruction
can the prime minister tell us who gave
his government
the democratic right to renege on the
uk's obligations
under the nuclear non-proliferation
treaty
minister
uh thank you mr speaker well
uh this government continues to invest
massively in uh projects that will be
benefit to the whole of the uk including
to to scotland and i can tell him that
uh there'll be further investments in in
in los angeles
uh that uh there is no threat for
instance to the black watch which i know
that
uh he and his colleagues uh sometimes
like to raise in order to
uh to alarm people uh we will continue
to invest massively in
uh overseas development aid which he
which he rightly
uh mentions and we're very proud of what
we're doing and by the way that delivers
500 jobs
in east kilbride we'll continue to
invest in in shipbuilding which drives
jobs across the whole of the uk
and and particularly uh in scotland and
i think it's a fantastic thing
to see those ships being built uh by
apprentices in govan
as he has as i'm sure uh the only thing
that endangers
those investments and working together
as one uk
working with all the fantastic people in
the armed services
in scotland is the reckless referendum
uh which i think his party insists on
calling uh
in the most in opposite time possible
for this country
we now come to the chair of the slate
committee to myself thank you very much
mr speaker this i've very much welcomed
the comprehensive ambition set out
in this important integrated review
paper today there is a 1930s feel to the
scale of challenges that we face today
with rising
authoritarian powers weak global
institutions
and an absence of western leadership and
collective resolve
i was hoping for a fulton missouri
moment mr speaker when we finally
call out china for the geo-strategic
threat that it is and a commitment to
our aid budget
but i do hope the prime minister will
summon that atlantic charter
spirit of working together with our
closest ally of the united states
to strengthen the rules-based order such
as advancing the g7
to the to the g10 which could form the
backbone to revising trade
and security standards that our ever
dangerous world so desperately needs
prime minister i i thank my uh
right honourable friend and uh i i must
say that i think that
there is a balance to be uh to be struck
because
after all uh we have a
strong trading relationship with china
worth about 81 billion pounds china is
the
second largest economy in the world and
a fact of our lives and i think
uh we must accept that fact in a
clear-eyed way but we've also got
to be tough where we see risk and that's
why this government has brought in
uh the national security and investment
bill uh to protect our
intellectual property that's why we're
protecting our critical national
infrastructure that's why
my right on offense the uh foreign
secretary has done more than
virtually any other foreign secretary
around the world to call out what china
is doing
in in xinjiang and that's why this
government
has offered uh a uh place a refuge and
abode
to three million hong kong chinese who
may be in fear of persecution as a
result of what is happening
in hong kong this government takes a
very very clear-eyed
approach to what is happening in china
it is a balanced approach and one that i
think
the british people understand show the
pscm
thank you mr speaker well mr speaker
we've heard a lot of words like ambition
and innovation so let me bring the prime
minister a little bit down back down to
earth
and see we have an aircraft carrier
strike group with not enough aircraft
and not enough ships to support it we
have rotting
nuclear submarines not a single one that
has been decommissioned
we have a living accommodation for
single and family
uh single personnel and families that is
woefully inadequate and needing
investment
quite simply mr speaker the mass doesn't
add up
the gap in what's needed to just deliver
what's in plan now
is huge even with the additional
investment so perhaps the prime minister
could level with the house
the country and our armed forces and
tell us now
what's going to be cut so this can be
afforded prime minister
i i i thank her but she should recognize
that this is the biggest commitment in
spending
on our armed forces since the end of the
cold war labor left a black hole in our
defense money
of 38 billion 38 billion yes the sca did
yesterday mr speaker this is a massive
investment
and it's designed it is designed to deal
with the
chronic problems that have the previous
governments
have failed to address modernizing our
forces
uh with uh ai uh with a future combat
air system and finally moving into cyber
i think that is the investment the
hard-edged investment
this country needs to modernize our
forces and take them forward labour
consistently failed
to do that let's come to dr julian lewis
as the prime minister just mentioned the
national security and investment bill i
hope i can
rely on him to help the intelligence and
security committee remove the obstacles
that are being placed in our way in
wishing to scrutinize the work of its
investment security unit now though
there are strong analytical
aspects to this review it's suggested on
pages
62-3 that our adversary
communist china quotes is an
increasingly important partner in
tackling
global challenges like pandemic
preparedness if you please and that we
want deeper trade links and more
chinese investment in the uk doesn't
that unfortunately demonstrate
that the grasping naivety of the cameron
osborne years still lingers on in some
departments of state
prime minister mr speaker those who call
for a new cold war
uh on china or for us to sequester our
economy entirely from china which seems
to be
uh the new policy of of the opposition
weaving as they
generally do from one uh position to the
next are i think
are i think mistaken uh we have a
balance to strike and we needed to have
a clear-eyed
relationship with china of course we're
protecting our critical
national infrastructure we'll continue
to do that and
we will make sure that through the
security and investments bill uh we
we protect our uh our national uh we
protect
our intellectual property and we will
take tough measures as i have said
to call out china for what they're doing
in xinjiang
and uh there is no one around the world
who has done more on that matter
than my right honourable friend the
foreign secretary or this government we
will continue to do that
companies that profit from trade
enforced
labor will not be allowed to do so in
this country
and i think the whole house should be
very proud of what we're doing
let's go to sarah champion sarah
thank you mr speaker i'm really shocked
that development is barely mentioned in
the integrated review
when will the prime minister understand
that full tummies economic opportunity
and stable governments
create the stronger safer and more
prosperous world that he wants not more
nuclear weapons
when we look at the cuts that we know of
so far cuts to the conflict stability
and security fund 80
cuts in aid corruption work how does
this make sense to create this stable
world
when does the government plan to publish
its development strategy
will it actually consult with the ngos
the global south
and indeed parliament and the in idc on
this review
please tell us we need to know the
details
mr speaker as i as i've as i've just
explained the
development and mains remains an
absolutely critical part of
the uk's uh foreign and overseas policy
and
uh 10 billion pounds is being spent this
year
given what this country has been going
through given that we've been
uh obliged to spend 280 billion pounds
to prop up jobs and livelihoods another
63 billion pounds
to support the nhs 37 billion pounds
37 billion pounds on uh supporting local
councils i think it's up to
members opposite to say which of that
support for the nhs
they would cut what they would reduce to
spend more on overseas eight of course
we want
the percentage to go back up again when
fiscal circumstances
allowed i think people of common sense
understand that 10 billion pounds
is a huge sum uh in the current
circumstances
and they will appreciate that it is
right to wait until fiscal circumstances
have improved
thank you mr speaker i very much welcome
the integrated reviewers it's set out
and i welcome its aspiration to
coherence i also welcome
the fact that many of the ideas not just
the author have been stolen
from the foreign affairs committee and
on that i am very grateful
but may i ask that some of the aspects
that we have touched on the past few
years
are addressed in the strategies that
have not been
clarified in today's paper strategies on
artificial intelligence
and indeed uh on different forms of
financial
threats because where we need to see
the uk setting up for ourselves is not
just in aid and sticking to the 0.7
which the prime minister has already
touched on but also
in platforms making sure that we don't
just
reallocate aid to defence but we
actually increase the number of ships
so that our presence in the east is real
and not
digital we also need to look hard at the
new threats from cryptocurrency
to the financial missed dealings in the
city of london that threaten our
national security
so obviously whether that's dirty
russian money or increasingly
dirty chinese money we need to stand up
for britain's interests and bring these
tools together
this is a very very welcome start but
will he please put some meat on those
bones
and make sure that when we hear the
command paper next week
we don't find that this is a snowstorm
without the pounds attached
prime minister uh mr speaker it's a
pretty big blizzard of a snowstorm when
you consider this 24 billion pounds
uh and the biggest investment uh since
the cold war and
uh and we cover uh every aspect of the
uh
subjects that he's just raised from
artificial intelligence to the threat of
uh crypto currencies and it remains the
uh the case that the uk uh under these
proposals uh we'll continue to be able
to project one of the few countries in
the world
to be able to project force 8 000 miles
thanks to our carrier
strike force and we are making the
investments
now we are making the investments now
that are grasping the nettle
that have such previous governments have
failed to grasp for decades
let's go to leila moran okay and then we
have it
um the prime minister live in the
commons after he made that statement
outlining the conclusions of that
integrated review of